uh I'm Winston Chang I'm a uh software
engineer at posit and um earlier this
year I did some work on a package called
chat stream which you can use to help
build AI chat
applications uh with shiny for Python
and it just sort of looks like this you
if you can't read this it's fine it's
you know it's just basically a chat
interface you ask it a question and it
gives you an answer it talks to the open
AI API uh and that gives you an answer
and you can have a conversation with
it um and when I was working on this I
showed this to the team and we were
trying to figure out some fun demos to
do with it um and Joe Chang had the idea
like well what if you have it play the
game 20 questions what if you have two
of these on a page one of them thinks of
an object the other one tries to guess
what that object is so I went and I
figured out how to wire up these two um
two instances of this uh shiny module to
talk to each other take the outputs from
one of them and use it for the inputs of
the other and vice versa so and so again
this is going to be really small I
didn't realize this room was going to be
like this but you don't have to read
this it's not that important um this is
it the two of these modules talking to
each other doing uh playing the game of
questions um now we we've shown this
elsewhere and I was thinking today for
today I want to do something a little
bit different um so I was thinking like
how can I how can we make this better
and I thought well you know what might
be fun is if they're doing uh now
instead of playing 20 questions you have
these two chat Bots doing a debate about
a topic so I went and I changed the
application a little bit um I don't if
the cursor will show up there anyway on
the top you can enter in your topic
there's these two chat Bots um so here
the debating you know llms have
subjective experience versus they don't
have subjective experience if you're you
know if you're a philosophy of Mind
person um you'll know what this this all
means and then they have this debate
about it and you can uh you can you know
you read this and this actually it's
it's it's kind of interesting to to
engage with an argument this way by um
to learn about something by reading it
this way but I still thought you know
that's a little bit dull to have these
two AI chat Bots doing it so I thought
you know how can I make this how can I
make that better um how can I make it
more interesting and I and I
realized this could be like a um it
could be like a Socratic dialogue where
you have
characters that are doing this argument
right so in ocratic dialogue just remind
everyone you have uh you have these
characters so uh here we have
protagoras uh and Socrates here and they
might be debating something like you
know the nature of virtue ethics what
does it mean to live a good life so I
went and I uh updated my application a
little bit and added a field where you
can type in you can also add in the
character that you want to embody like
one of these a chat bots so there's
character and topic and this is you know
protagoras and Socrates arguing about uh
virtue ethics so this was you know the
results from this were really fun and
interesting it's a little bit more
compelling reading it coming from a
character um rather than just a generic
chatbot
um and some of the results were I mean
it is interesting and some of them you
know some of the output was like also
rhetorically very
impressive um
and uh and I was thinking to myself like
well that's cool how can I you know how
can I make this even more interesting so
I I picked a topic that I thought was uh
I think everyone will resonate with
everyone here and some characters I
think everyone will be familiar with and
um I had it generate some dialogue and
and then I I I thought okay it would be
really it would be even better if this
were a song so I went and I didn't edit
the app to generate songs because that's
like Way Beyond what I'm capable of
doing but I found someone on the
internet who um who makes songs using a
generated voices which is very is really
cool and also a little bit creepy that
they can do that um and anyway I'd like
to play for you the song all
right prank turn it up get some base
too python tries hard but can't beat the
vision so Bigg what you got python ain't
got no
big Smalls on the M Pyon my choice
thatta clean
listen St Pyon automatic make you pic
with magic while just
tragic like aake no need to fake python
takig you ain't the
deeph your data right Python's got
pandas yo step out of the fight
bioinformatics RS in the Limelight RS
like aun always ready to
ignite learn night a de learning pythons
may aood but python
pip Pyon like a Bigg track it tight
Snoop R's the king Python's just R's got
the visuals Python's just residuals your
python is minimal my R is the Pinnacle
analyzing data using r as my manipulator
python Environ giv Vibes like an early
beta you know it's true ours got the
prime
crew just a stage on the learning ramp
python gotu all jumbl your are stumble
my python hum so Snoop that they have
their you said it big let's set the
record straight using Python and off for
the knowledge they
facilitate
all right that's it thanks
[Applause]
everybody